from tearful runny noses to iconic
improvised lines anyone can quote these
monologues are pure movie Magic
Charlie Chaplin's speech in The Great
Dictator is often listed among the great
movie monologues and for good reason
it's hard to think of a better speech
than this one as it perfectly
encapsulates the hopeful Spirit of the
movie while also making an important
political statement The Great Dictator
is Chaplin's first sound film and is one
of the greatest satires of all time
chaplain plays two characters a Jewish
Barber and former Soldier and a Nazi
dictator named adenoid Hinkle a parody
of Adolf Hitler The Barber and heanco
look alike of course and at one point in
the film Hinkle's men mistake him for
the barber and to rest him causing the
barber to take Hinkle's place the famous
monologue comes at the end as the barber
dressed as Hinkle makes an impassioned
speech to the public do not despair the
misery that is now upon us is but the
passing of greed the bitterness of men
who fear the way of human progress he
urges the soldiers to rise up and defy
their masters the people of the world to
embrace kindness instead of hate and
those currently in bondage to have hope
the fact that this film was released in
1940 after the Nazis had already risen
to power makes the scene even more
impactful but Chaplin's message is just
as important today as it was back then
it's a perfect speech and true movie
Magic
trying to put him down I had a title
shot I was ready that night Marlon
Brando is a master of the monologue so
it's no surprise that two of his films
feature on this list one of his most
famous pieces of dialogue comes from a
film in the early days of his career
1954's on the waterfront Brando plays
Terry Malloy a former champion boxer who
now works as a longshoreman in New
Jersey his career went up in smoke when
mob boss Johnny friendly convinced him
to throw a fight and now he's mustering
up the courage to testify against
friendly in court in the most famous
scene in the film Terry is in the back
of a car with his older brother Charlie
Terry reminds Charlie that he was the
one who told Terry to throw the match on
behalf of friendly something he still
blames him for
I could have been a contender
I could have been somebody despite
Brando's slur drawl the lines are
crystal clear and the despair in his
voice is right there on the surface the
scene is quite brief but Brando reveals
everything we need to know about the
character here his bitterness his
longing for a different life and how
he's been living all this time with a
broken heart
Harper Lee's To Kill a Mockingbird is
often considered one of the Great
American novels and the film adaptation
is held in similarly high regard Gregory
Peck plays Atticus Finch a single father
and principled lawyer Finch takes on the
case of Tom Robinson a black man accused
of raping a white woman Finch knows
Robinson has very little chance of
winning the case due to the deep-seated
racism of the South but he puts up an
impassioned effort to get him off
anyways in his final speech to the
courtroom Finch knows he's fighting a
losing case and he's all but lost the
jury he successfully proven Robinson's
innocence but is struggling to change
the hearts and minds of his fellow
citizens in our courts
all men are
created
equal he urges the jury to do their Duty
and follow the evidence not their
Prejudice though he knows they very
likely will not it's a Powerhouse
performance by Peck and it's considered
some of his best work the guardian
reports that novelist Harper Lee was so
happy with his take on Finch who is
based on her own father that she gave
him her father's old pocket watch this
powerful courtroom scene proves what an
impressive actor Peck is and why the
film deserves its elevated status in the
Cinematic Canon
you're gonna need a bigger boat the
making of Steven Spielberg's Jaws is
legendary Bruce the shark kept
malfunctioning there was Major tension
on set and the film went way over budget
still despite these troubles the film
contains one of the greatest movie
monologues of all time a scene that is
also a favorite of Spielberg's according
to den of geek the monologue is
delivered by Quint the grizzled Captain
Ahab like Shark Hunter who joins Hooper
and Brody on their boat the Orca sitting
in the cabin one evening Quint shares
the harrowing real-life story of the USS
Indianapolis an event that mirrors their
own predicament he describes the 1945
disaster Eleven Hundred men in the war
316 men come out and the Sharks took the
rest Spielberg explained in a
documentary that the scene was a Rosetta
Stone for quint's entire character
because it reveals all of his
motivations and why he feels so strongly
about sharks the scene is delivered with
a perfectly garbled draw by Robert Shaw
who according to Coast screenwriter Carl
Gottlieb actually rewrote much of the
scene himself as evidenced by the
shocked faces of Hooper and Brody
quint's tale has a distressing effect on
his companions as they can only imagine
the horrors he's experienced it's the
most grounded restrained scene in a
movie that is often said to have
invented the crowd-pleasing summer
blockbuster and it's among Spielberg's
best work
network is one of the great films of the
1970s and its brilliant take on the
dissolution of Television ethics is
still relevant today the film follows
old school news anchor Howard Beale
who's forced into retirement after a
drop in the ratings peel is incensed and
goes on a televised rant in front of the
nation the most popular monologue in the
film is probably beale's famous tirade I
must mad as hell and I'm not gonna take
this anymore still the most compelling
monologue in the film comes closer to
the end when Beale meets with Arthur
Jensen the chairman of the conglomerate
that owns the network Jensen tries to
convince Beale to abandon his
anti-capitalist sermon by teaching him
how the world really works Jensen at the
far end of a very long table tellsbeel
you have meddled with a primal forces of
nature her bill and I won't have it he
adds that there is only one natural
force that rules the world money it's an
extremely Bleak sentiment but his
booming voice and the unique way the
scene is shot with the camera getting
closer and closer to Jensen as the
monologue goes on makes it impossible to
tear your eyes away
Francis Ford Coppola's Apocalypse Now is
one of the most famous movies ever
perhaps partly because the behind the
scenes drama has become so legendary
still despite the harrowing
circumstances of the film's production
Coppola was able to capture some of the
greatest scenes in film history there
are a number of celebrated moments in
Apocalypse Now but one monologue in
particular stands out Marlon Brando was
famously difficult to work with on set
but all of that Strife resulted in a
scene involving Colonel Kurtz bathed in
Shadow the Rogue kernel Kurtz recounts
the horrors of War reflecting on the
circumstances that have brought him to
the Jungle where he now rules his own
small Kingdom Kurtz tells Martin Sheen's
Captain Willard
or is that you've seen but you have no
right to call me a murderer you have a
right to kill me he goes on to describe
these Horrors in detail explaining how
he felt when he saw children who had
their arms chopped off and thrown in a
pile having seen the worst of humanity
Curts has abandoned his own sense of
morality and descended into a kind of
principled insanity much of Kurtz's
dialogue was based on Brando's own
improvisations and despite the effort
that clearly went into the complicated
performance the scene feels effortless
film characters don't often have the
chance to make philosophical speeches
just before their deaths but in a world
filled with robots things work a little
differently the original Blade Runner
film gives us one of the greatest sci-fi
monologues of all time delivered by a
replicant a humanoid robot named Roy
Batty the film follows Rick Deckard a
former Blade Runner whose job was to
hunt down and kill replicants who are
now seen as a threat to humanity Baddie
is one of the Rogue replicants that it
has been sent to kill and his final
scene is one of the greatest sci-fi
moments ever captured on film Patty
saves deckard's life and then realizing
his time is up reflects on the nature of
his existence I'm
seen things you people wouldn't believe
he describes the amazing things he's
seen in his short lifetime summing up
the experience by saying all those
moments will be lost in time like tears
in rain the monologue itself is only 42
words long but it packs an incredible
punch aided by Rutger Howard's
magnificent performance and a quietly
soaring soundtrack power told radio
times that he actually rewrote parts of
the scene himself including that iconic
final line it's arguably the most
important moment in the movie as it
proves just how human the replicants
really are one death scene to rule them
all
vimvendor's 1984 film Paris Texas is
about a man lost at sea well more
precisely it's about a man lost in the
desert but the metaphor is still out
Harry Dean Stanton plays Travis
Henderson a man who has been missing for
many years the recently rescued Travis
reconnects with his brother and Son but
soon finds himself on a journey to
locate the mother of his child Jane he
finds Jane in Houston at the Peep Show
Club where she works he sees her behind
a one-way mirror and decides to finally
speak to her Travis tells Jane their
story starting with the time they met
and fell in love and ending with the
violent dissolution of their Union the
10-minute long scene is beautifully
directed by vendors who alternates
between focusing the camera on Travis as
he's telling the tale and Jane who
slowly begins to realize the story is
about her sounds like they were very
happy
yes they were they were real happy it's
a master class an empathetic
storytelling as it's difficult not to
feel for both characters even as Travis
describes the terrible way he treated
Jane Paris Texas won the Palm door at
the Khan film festival in 1984 and this
scene is likely a huge reason why a slow
burning monologue filled with
resignation and regret it's an
enormously affecting moment many of the
Great monologues in film history come
from equally great films but this isn't
always the case in his storied career Al
Pacino has delivered countless powerful
speeches in movies like The Godfather
and Scarface however one of his most
celebrated monologues is from a film
that is often forgotten 1992's Scent of
a Woman Pacino plays Lieutenant Colonel
Frank Slade a blind cantankerous Vietnam
veteran planning to end his life Frank's
niece hires Charlie a prep student in
trouble for refusing to Rattle his
classmates to look after Frank over
Thanksgiving Frank spends much of the
movie acting like a mean angry old man
but he swoops in at the end to save the
day Charlie is forced to sit through a
hearing led by his crooked Headmaster
who thinks he should be expelled for
refusing to inform on his peers Frank
then enters the courtroom and gives an
impassioned speech about the importance
of courage and integrity qualities which
seem to have been lost on the Headmaster
but Chino is known for turning things up
to 11 in climactic moments and his
performance here isn't exactly subdued
but he gives Frank's righteous speech a
rousing dramatic Flair it's a classic
Hollywood monologue that stands the test
of time even if the film itself has not
I show you on order
you don't know what that order is Mr
trash Robin Williams is something of a
master advice giver in films and nowhere
is this more apparent than in the 1997
film Goodwill Hunting Williams plays
Sean McGuire a therapist who is
counseling and young genius
mathematician named Will Hunting played
by Matt Damon Williams has several
impactful monologues in just this film
alone but there's one that stands out
though Sean has been working to break
through Will's defense mechanisms and
get to know the real him will continues
to treat therapy like a joke and even go
so far as to insult Sean and his dead
wife Sean and will sit together on a
park bench one day and Sean takes will
to task for his childish arrogance he
tells will that he may know things about
the world from reading books but he's
never actually lived in the world as
Sean has I can't learn anything from you
I can't read in some book
unless you want to talk about you it's a
talking down to you that will rightly
deserves and it eventually leads to the
famous therapy breakthrough scene later
in the film when will admits to being
abused as a child
it's not your fault the latter scene is
the more memorable one but this earlier
scene is an important building block for
the film as a whole and Williams gives a
typically wisened performance here
Denzel Washington is one of the great
contemporary masters of the movie
monologue and you don't have to look far
to find some legendary ones from Malcolm
X to Philadelphia to Macbeth he's an
actor of almost unparalleled strength
and gravitas one of his very best
monologues is not a political speech or
a drawn-out soliloquy but a short
volatile scene from the 2001 film
Training Day Washington plays Alonso
Harris a crooked LAPD cop who's forced
to start working with a rookie played by
Ethan Hawke by the time we get to
Washington's greatest monologue alonso's
time has started to run out though he
previously ruled the neighborhood with
an iron fist his hold on the community
is starting to slip and the Russian mob
has a hit out on him he tries to
reassert his dominance by giving a
threatening speech to the local gang
members and onlookers
King Kong ain't got
training day may be a gritty crime movie
but this scene feels very Shakespearean
in nature which makes sense considering
Washington is a Shakespeare trained
actor though he's trying to remain in
Alpha you can hear the desperation
behind his threats and Washington's
dramatic rhythm is spot on Washington's
work here is made all the more
impressive when you consider that he
improvised the famous King Kong line
which marks the powerful climax in this
speech
Paul Thomas Anderson is a filmmaking
Legend with numerous beloved films under
his belt but one scene and one line of
dialogue stands above them all Daniel
day-lewis's delivery of this line from
the 2007 film There Will Be Blood is one
of the most iconic lines of the 21st
century and is a small part of a great
cinematic monologue the line comes in
the film's final scene as the two Rivals
face off Eli Sunday is a preacher who
has long tried to seize power from the
megalomaniac Daniel Plainview Daniel
holds a grudge against Eli because of
the time Eli forced him into a baptism
so when Eli comes to Daniel's door like
a beggar Daniel can't help but point out
his hypocrisy Eli offers to sell a piece
of his oil-rich land to Daniel and
Daniel tells him that he's already
drained the land leading to this famous
line I drink your milkshake Eli made a
huge mistake coming to Daniel like this
as Daniel has reverted into the worst
version of himself misanthropic cruel
and Bloated with wealth while the
milkshake line is incredible the
cruelest life comes earlier you just
after birth Eli no slithered out on your
mother's filth the scene ends with
Daniel killing Eli with a bowling pin
completing Daniel's transformation into
a man devoid of humanity chilling stuff
any movie monologue list needs at least
one Viola Davis scene and her
performance in fences is among her best
if you weren't convinced of Davis's
Brilliance before this movie you
certainly will be afterward fences is an
adaptation of the August Wilson play of
the same name and follows a married
couple Troy and Rose along with their
son Corey Troy never got over his dream
of becoming a professional baseball
player and he takes his frustrations out
on his wife and son in one climactic
scene Rose confronts Troy about his
cheating and he tries to justify it by
explaining how hard it's been
it's not easy for me to admit that I've
been standing in the same place for 18
years well I've been standing with you
with tears streaming down your face and
it's not literally dripping into her
mouth Rose lays out her desolation
explaining how she had to bury her wants
and needs to stay married to Troy and
find a reason to keep living Troy
doesn't reflect on Rose's feelings of
course but she lays them out with
devastating Clarity I took all my
feelings my wants and needs and dreams
I'm putting myself inside you and waited
to bloom Davis gives a tour to force
performance here the kind you have to
remind yourself to breathe while
watching proving that she's really in a
league of her own
foreign